well you need a mask name if you don't
dude I just came up with a [ __ ] brand
and a business mask mask mask list help
me with this I want the viewers to know
Brian saw the insanely worldwide success
thick boy by Club has that okay and he
don't make me mad but yeah it's it's is
well that's what are you doing it's very
success thank you oh no big deal yeah
made a business during this alright
here's the thing though dude
so now Brian's won't stop pestering me
to come up with a business idea I'm an
entrepreneur when I say you're the worst
entreprenuer in the world well you bad
okay I understand that I'm Steve Jobs
yeah you don't have a job I understand
that I'm not that good right now but
like with everything you learn it takes
a long time and I think I'm late some
years now I'm ready to bust out never
had a good eye listen first of all guys
there's a huge [ __ ] this stupid crazy
like then boy then boy cruisers you know
thank you for that
they thank you but I can't like that's
that's Brennan's idea I'm not gonna bite
take thi n and end boy we sell Cruiser
put it Dan boy Christmas we don't bike
but we walk we stroll through all life's
toast we don't do anything then boys
drawl yeah so not start at Twilight
cruisers we're by the end of this
[ __ ] podcast I'm gonna come up with a
[ __ ] company and I'm gonna come up
with a [ __ ] product I said it and if
I don't if I don't nothing's gonna
happen I'm gonna [ __ ] throw my face
into that watch into that [ __ ] table
I'd like that and I'm gonna flatten my
own face oh oh oh I like that
Oh could be a great party you you did
give daddy the initial startup fee to
start my merchandise business you gave
me you gave me two grand to create find
the kid sheriff give me the initial
investment I forgot about that so you
got your money back
I say you got your money back and I do
some would even say you still owe me a
ton of money well but we're gonna get
about that what if you wet murdered you
how was gonna forget about that the bike
don't need any more
but what if you well I'm thin what what
if on the mascot and you don't have a
snake
think about it think about it to repay
you
you little snake yes like a couple of
Viper dude nope
okay a rattler nope okay a gardener yes
I don't even get to be a rattler I'm
gonna be a gardener maybe a little
stupid gardener are you gonna make me
what scared of it are you gonna make me
like this and wiggle around we're gonna
glue your hands to your side really
gonna tape your hands to your side
what do I make for that no no you don't
make anything this is part of the
business piece of the company it's mark
I need to buy a house I'm having house
problems as you know I'm having the
house pretty bribry needs money there's
700 good I don't know you're making me
mad all right are you becoming in you
bothering me I've had the p-diddy a
podcast I don't know hey have you said I
didn't say that it I didn't say that
[ __ ] man I gotta come up with a [ __ ]
company hey dude
imma let you in we fold shirts I'm not
folding inserts a piece of [ __ ] too busy
I got three TV shows believe it or not
and that's the other problem I should
worry about my TV shows I shouldn't be
worried about this I do want to start my
own [ __ ] money companies still know
what no I came to you with nothing then
the big lie all right bill said all day
beyond thing about you dancing all day I
said man money so much I gotta come up
with a company hey are there any
entrepreneurs out there that want to
start a company with me oh this is like
the Rick and Morty though you want to
start an app you want to start an app
and he starts an app it creates a love
love up and takes over the world you
want to start an app I love app would be
good
what's your type and you plug it in dude
how about a dude just spitballing ideas
here how about a old person's love app
it's called drinks it's called wrinkles
rinks isn't just my older like milk you
know some people call me now I'm on my
comments Gary
hey tarts sweet sweeter now I'll get
eight tarts hey man tarts and rinks do
but how about how about a love app
called rinks or wrinkles I like wrinkles
I like the rinks is good I got to make
some t-shirts for rinks sure whatever it
is so hundred here's the thing Hey so
we'll do wrinkles and it's just old
people looking for love it's a good idea
dude wrinkles
where'd you met wrinkles wearing diapers
don't you mean battles then we shop the
just unbelievable milf on there with
their wrinkles yeah or dude here's
nothing wrinkles I think it's gotta be
something good like wrinkles and honey
no honey no would call it honey rings
but how about this
it's rink it's it's called wrinkles and
we hook up old people with sugar babies
that's ever really a good idea Spacey
riot but just for old people it's a
really good idea they're not good you
don't have to be famous or said be old
silver singles oh well there goes my dad
[ __ ] silver singles and they're charging
wrinkles singles wrinkles and jingle
wrinkles in singles singles
oh no here's this singles with wrinkles
is you that shingles singles with
wrinkles with shingles now that's good
how about this dude how about this Six
Feet Under
got problems with your Six Feet Under
and then you like swipe right on old
Pete skeletons no rattle eighty days
laughing goes what who's into it no
singles with wrinkles I just came up
with my amazing company singles with
wrinkles singles rankings great nap got
problems with that with your digestion
pissing more than normal where you're
[ __ ] 30% off Botox October only ah
yeah eyeballs hang low but we have
positive value having issues with
incontinence gray pubes were your your
socks bunch up around your socks or your
ankles are skinny that's good dude why
would my ankles be skinny you know
people they're all lose all the hair
down there you ever notice how Oh people
old men have no hair on their [ __ ]
but I do on there like a good
circulation yeah they lose their hair no
really most guys who are starting
started like 45 but I do I owe the
hairless cats hairless cancer ruin here
let's cat hairless cats look at those
ankles I'll tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
Oh [ __ ] business